negli episodi precedenti di residenti vo
porca [ __ ] mi sono scagliato nelle
mutande non ti lascerà stato ma dov'era
non vedo che non possono funzionare a
tutto la mi chieda attacchi anche l'asta
che funziona perfetta spacca duro come
bomba è staccato e gorriano ma penso
adesso per tu hai mandare all'aria la
caccia fuga ho capito lega ho capito
tutto diventano vulnerabili quando piano
freddo come me d'inverno aia porca [ __ ]
ecco perché la mamma mi fa sempre uscire
col cappotto che dice premi fredde e
schianta madonna mi quanto tempo o che
finora che hanno capito che dimezza
strega di merda è già qui loro muoiono
loro muoiono quando prendono freddo mi
chiama stare parlavo più capitali o poi
anche scendere tra l'altro se scende di
quota mazzi sicuro però potresti
scendere perché è basso ma non si può
prescindere peccato c'è qualcosa di
rischio di animare su una base de grazia
è aperto tutto molto bene non ho capito
a cosa mi serve sto teschio ma va bene è
stata una figata raga ma tra l'altro sta
posto posto qua era anche se potevo
anche non raggiungerlo o si serve
proprio per andare avanti nel gioco sto
teschio di animale schifoso non lo so va
bè ragazzi chi se ne frega acqua c'è
anche qualcosa che se no minchia ecco
cosa serve lo devo mettere qua perché
sennò non si apre la porta che si è
chiusa la porta di merda cosa faccio
maschera le piace con la maschera si
apre se la prendo sicura
ma [ __ ] cosa faccio non trovare
una maschera fake minchia che palle raga
ho trovato la massima non puoi non puoi
prenderti con le lance uguale la stessa
cosa teschio di animale ma porca vacca
morta vabbè fischiato la maschera
tornerà a prenderla e ranieri è sempre
un bel vedere però santo iddio un attimo
qua mi scusi no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no ti prego di hamas che
pur di non contrarre la maschera
minchia che ansia link è che bene il
bello è che quando mi vede è bellissima
questa cosa
madonna notarmi mi posso uscire di qua
per farlo per sondare qualche parte
senza rotture di palle
qui non ci posso andare
faccio il giro da sotto e perciò è
l'unico modo perché se no non riesco a
farmi niente mi sono rifatto tutto il
giro ragazzi sono arrivato fino a qua
che era tutto nei sotterranei che magari
se a prove meglio veloci è però veloce
velo quanto tempo perfetto grazie che
c'è troppo fermi fermi fermi fermi non
aprite la porta seguito vero ma non
hanno ancora capito come sempre la forza
io scherzavo
non pensavo fosse così avanzati nell'era
moderna di a saper usare una maniglia in
cantina sua ford ka portare con sé ma li
avevo fatti politici e costruttori sono
spunti sono spronati perché non c'erano
più ora è male picchia stato anche vabbè
lo sfacciato tutto spacca stato anche
sbagliando mira tra l'altro è tutto sto
casino dove ai ragazzi avviciniamo
stappare teoricamente dovrebbe prendere
fuoco
se riesco a fare se riesco è che non è
detto ho mica ce l'ho fatta un ora sono
stato ho mica l'ho dovuto lanciare per
colpirlo un casino c'è un sarcofago
spero ci sia una maschera a sto punto
no però c'è un occhio
tutto sto casino per l'occhio azzurro
che non ho idea di che cosa farmene
sinceramente è che non ne faccio di un
occhio azzurro
ok ragazzi altro giro altra porta che
dovrebbe essere qua dietro se non è
eccola qua che per chiusa proprio eccola
qua con la chiave mai madonna che
cacchio di roberto chissà quando
torneremo nel villaggio quando quando
quando le porte da aprire già non mi sei
venuto ad essi
signa non si se non hai le mosche
intorno anche meglio però vabbè dai fa
niente
prendiamo per buono quello che devo
trovare un modo per aprire la finestra
perché ormai ho capito che devo fare sta
cosa
non so come però vabbè posso entrare qua
dentro e non si può in treno parte da
per forza
torno indietro allora non soffitto
forse devo pagare il soffitto
non staccare capito che devo trovare un
modo ragazzi e che se non mi fa non si
vuole uscire può offrirci qualcosa qui
si fa ma ragazzi ma veramente la fate
schifo è infatti è stato un po cattiva
sta cosa avete un punto debole che una
merda
beh perché sicuro non ci faccio le
scorte prestazione sia questo lo
specchio in casa domaso famosissima e mi
fai con quattro interesse sono un sogno
sono un incubo la zia prossima volta che
la finestra chiusa mente le zanzariere e
sono cazzi tua almeno a frutta in una
stanza che non c'ha finestre almeno
quello nicchia mi sto anche presenti
sono più proiettili haga da provare è
morta meno male perché hanno finito i
proiettili del fucile o tutto è bene ciò
che finisce sul ghiaccio le manca una se
non sbaglio quante ne ha fatte fuori tre
non erano quattro sorelle erano tre le
ho fatte fuori tutte sono morti tutte
sono bravissimo che bello finalmente
allora possiamo andare avanti
yes man sarà un po incazzata la mi fone
in bianco ma chi se ne frega maschera
della gioia ok non trovate ne manca
ancora una ragazza so anche dove no
scusate mi mancano due niente cagato ha
detto cagata quest'anno sblocchiamo a
nessuno minchia era la porta dell'atrio
questa pensate o e poi c'è l'atelier che
non ha ancora visto
si apre ci si apre pesando molto bello
va bene enel l'atelier non ho ben capito
cosa devo fare cioè sinceramente c'è un
quadro lo prendo
cosa c'è scritto questo è mario schifano
arabe dillo subito far sì che le cinque
campane di suoni no va bene
la campania 1 nice
e un anno presa ci sono altre cene una
storia dato anche può dire che sono qua
posso anche fare col coltello ha suonato
ecco infatti due cioè solo qua ce ne
sono cinque in tutto la tela eccola lì
mamma frey
ok 4 sul soffitto ce n'è una sicuro sul
lampadario guarda ci scommetto quello
che vuoi è quella si sia una campana
nice
4 ne manca una una due tre quattro ne
manca una che ne so io a minchia praga
ma sto male bellissimo ma dove non
l'avevo vista proprio che figata
apriti 6 canoa ma non è questo che si
della presolana così incredibile resto
la vera intuibile la pramac e dove
saltarmi così tante era era abbastanza
chiaro
ma cosa devo fare qua ma che figo c'è
dell'erba secondo me i ragazzi non c'è
niente se non un tesoro perché non lo so
sto presentimento qua 78 quantità di
golpe giorno c'è un miliardo e mezzo di
colpi non so anche due sfondando troppo
belli estate ragazzi è stata una figata
ma di quelle pazzesche e pazze è
bellissimo è stato bellissimo bellissimo
dove che ci son finiti una capretta
d'armi fare da un proiettile
non siamo a vari di proietti ne abbiamo
un miliardo tanto poi finiscono i 5
secondi
salve o viscusi pensavo fosse morto e un
altro è inizia cosenza grazie molto bene
c'era solo lei mappa del tesoro ma co
dungeon cazzo diventato the binding of
isaac diventato soggiorno
minchia rega fucile ho trovato un
cecchino la te sto male ho trovato un
fucile da cecchino ma veramente porca
vacca ne è valsa la pena pasta cagata è
sporco demonio lo metto pietro 4
bellissimo ho tratto un fucile da
cecchino bellissima questo male
malissimo perfetto
eccolo chestanno ai cosi chicche chicche
so pipistrello ni via fuori dalle balle
ce la fa
siamo qua ok l'ascom e io fossi dovevo
arrivare veramente una parte del gioco
ci si aspetta tutta un'altra zona questa
e l'ascensore per ricollegare tutto che
però non all'energia mei che funzionano
come questo sia l'ascensore di sotto non
funziona scusa
porca [ __ ] schiaccia buono l'ho preso
133 colpi per questi ci vogliono meno
colpi pro prenderli in casinò con il
fatto ok madonna affittanza e vabbè
allora morto non ha preso una volta c'è
chi sono veramente storto altro che
cecchino va bene danno un sacco di soldi
si qua è stato va bene questo c'è un
altro caso che ma quindi ho sbloccato da
un'altra zona
vediamo minchia
sono sul tetto va bene capri stanza
intera gara ho fatto il suo centrali
gente è ma come cazzo bacio aspetta un
attacco più staccati cose lì la pasta
roba scusate la torre amica cielo fino a
800 eccomi la maschera fai da te lo
meriti
bellissimo ce l'ho fatta non tre su
quattro o anche la quarta perché se dove
sono dove anche la quarta questo
incastra di tutti se potessimo toccare
una bomba li ragazzi iscritti astrattiva
li faccio con tutti perché fermi ok ma
navale alla fiscalità
manca solo quello
ho usato 20 mila proiettili ma sono
morti tutti ragazze nomale eccolo coop
rhesus allora li ho fatti fuori tutti ho
preso la maschera quindi alla fine
bisognava anche fare questa parte non
era solo per un tesoro infatti ad un po
troppo per il tesoro e basta ok ho fatto
tutto quello che c'è da fare qua no mi
manca solo ascensore mista
vediamo perché la scienza l'ascensore
che mi porta dove prima non funzionava
adesso dovrebbe funzionare
ok vai minchia manca solo una ma l'ho
fatto tutto manca solo una maschera e
che so dove però non so come prenderla
perché come la prendo non posso uscire
quindi devo usare un'altra maschera per
rimpiazzarla con le classiche roba di
videogiochi
metti i residenti vola anche per e
specialmente dove metti un oggetto e
prendi quello giusto però non ho idea di
dove sia la maschera finta color fatto
cacchio lo seccate tutte le sorelle
questo stupido merda
dove vado vado di sopra veloce però
molto tempo
arrivederci arrivederci
è stato divertente incontrarla una trota
mi dispiace perché non sono mai fare ci
vorrebbe un po di intimità treno però
manca ma anche un po quella voglia di
conoscersi capito non so la cosa lo
deduco sarà che tu ammazzato tre figli
non lo so benetton e altre tre maschere
ok
manca solo una ne manca una che quella
lì non ho proprio idea di come fare a
prenderla la notte o trovo un altro
posto per uscire tipo di qua c'è un
altro passo per uscire
teoricamente tra l'altro si perché
potevo calarmi di sotto l'ala avesse
voglia di farlo potrebbe farlo però non
c'ha voglia come cacchio faccio
dimmi che dimmi che c'è sì sì sì ti
prego ok ce l'ho fatta ce l'ha fatta ce
l'ho fatta ho fatto sono capaci ed i
siti tipiche celo celo dovevo sfidarlo
maledetta sta cosa dire sentivo che ogni
volta manda in pappa il cervello uscire
da ogni volta che faccio sta cosa
ragazzi perché non viene mai a farlo da
ispezionare gli oggetti mai è una cosa
che non mi viene proprio automatica
perché proprio l'unico gioco che ce
l'hai non mi viene in mente mai di fare
questa cosa ogni volta che la faccio
succede alla roba
mamma mia togliti è l'unico punto a fine
anno qui una nicchia l'unico punto e
disabili vasselin
che palle questa odom apre giro sempre
stupida ha già fatta mais sono tutte e
quattro veloce apripista porta vista
porta veloce è però quanto tempo che c'è
la zia niente lo morire ovattati aperta
corri velocissimo non so dove sto
andando ma mai ci cardinale potente se
non ci fosse anche ok non c'entra ma
prendo stero valvole me ne vado è veloce
che non ne sono sicuro effetto
va bene ragazzi qua se non devo fare una
boss fight non lo so non era che il
problema sicura una volta è questa il
problema forse no non lo so torre della
devozione problema è che non ho proietti
visse una boss fight
speriamo che se non ho idea
c'è un sarà un altro ci manca solo
questo tutto sto casino per
altri carroccio meno male io capisco
persia e quello che torna indietro
l'effetto guarda me l'aspettavo
grazie del primo peccato un po per il
puntati aleppo coach al organi no mi
chiama e intanto guarda mi hai mozzato
vita braccio improvvisamente sei un
povero 38 fatti fuori tutti con i
volanti
marika [ __ ] io me ne andrei via ai
sexy una volta mar tipo un raga secondo
me sono cazzi miei
oppure pre time attoniti se non riesce a
uccidermi adesso raga siamo un po come
la battaglia di harry potter nei calici
di giornata prendi la scopa e 2 vado
vado dietro giro aspetto ma si prega di
merda è piaciuta questa breve che non è
colpita in iii sono cazzi miei
ma dai colpi questo è tutto da vedere
sia stato non proiettili ok fucile di
precisione vedi adatti
meno male qui non è così raro
come dire non mi ha colpito ma se sto
qua ritrovare porca [ __ ] stato
sistemato da depositare
così mica penso che culo
no no a crearmi te ecco questa è la
domanda se finiscono il migliore
no sono convinto di questo occhio la
coda il problema è che è un casino
colpirla
dice che base di cui 6 solo maker
dichiara che ha capito però che sto
facendo e ragga poco ma poi se continua
a sparare non prenderle al casinò c'è un
punto migliore dove posso provare a
sparare perché qua è merda
no no no no no no no no quale troverete
volete una rete ci entrano qua dentro
non entrano dentro si cosi meno male
amico porca [ __ ] e choc dice che male
va preso
muore era capiti colpi la pistola ottimo
passiamo con il fucile non avrei capito
se questo mi comprende ok adesso ho
capito
lo vivo ok amuchina veloce tattica
proprio bene verrà via via via si abbia
via via via via via via via via via via
via via delineando due terreni e via via
via ce l'ho fatta se n'è andata
meno male ha fatto crollare la torre ma
non fa niente una corretta ma ecco la
posso usare suu kyi la precisione
d'acqua
e difficilissimo colpirla lo stesso sica
mi sento un po power però senza la sua
mira è quella differenze ma così ragazzi
facciamo notte gazzetta capita mica è
morta
sega ha però dovevo aspettare cosa urlo
a fare molta attenzione genova 6
dateci che già difficile buono
ok ho usati tutti i ragazzi ecco la
mancata port chiamato solo per la
precisione raga poi ho finito se sono
quelli della mia arma più forte però
devo usare questi per fosse ok le ho
fatto abbastanza male però mi rimangono
13 proiettili di merda mi rimangono
pochissimi raga merda merda merda dove
futuro dei pazienti
presa e fuori
e morta in ortofrutta è morta ma perché
io parlo
cosa ci mettiamo lì
il ragazzo colpito dal
lo score ragazzi le sto facendo
malissimo però non ho più colpi tra un
po cieli affinity non sei
devo sfruttare 26 perché sennò un casino
non ne ho veramente più ragazzi non
muore il telefono morto io ok occhio
ha sfondato tutto fratelli ascoltato
tutto minchia norma così massimo la zia
che quel casino indica ci sono
proiettili qua detto che gli organi o
tre
ho finito proiettili si non ce l'ho più
4 proietti quattro sono più niente ho
solo lebbra le bombe ciò bomba una bomba
artigianale e 439 erano verso lo mangia
munizioni fucile gli altri 25 la pistola
ragazzi sono un po di respiro meno ma
sbaglia porta manca ma esita
male va male non male non male interiore
con sacco di volte la prendere
egli ha preso
di cucina ad aumentare ma meritato
meno mira ripetuto e ce ne vuole prodigo
è morta ott e morta
continua a dire morte non vuole mai
colpa
rischiato questo tempo
eh sì originaria che oggi è finito con
una caduta di stile
no c'è poco accaduto non può essere vivo
però non me lo voglio dire perché sennò
vi spolvero episodi di domani come
aspetto ragazzi servizio sul momento è
un mi piace anche vari social che come
nel video dato una descrizione seno se
dovessi iscrivetevi e noi come sempre ci
vediamo ad un prossimo video è la
ragazzi
[Musica]